let's now attempt to apply stokes
theorem and so over here we have this
little diagram and we have this path
that we're calling c and it's the
intersection of the plane y plus z is
equal to two so that's the plane that
kind of slants down slants down like
that it's the intersection of that plane
and the cylinder actually i shouldn't
even call it a cylinder because if you
just have x squared plus y squared is
equal to one it would essentially be
like a pole an infinite pole that keeps
going up forever and keeps going down
forever so it would never have a top or
bottom but we've sliced that pole with y
plus z is equal to two to get and where
they intersect we get our path c
we also have this vector field defined
in this way and we're asked to evaluate
the line integral of f dot dr over this
path with this orientation and we could
directly solve this line integral we've
done it before and actually we'll do it
again to show that we're getting the
same answer but this is about stoke's
theorem so let's see if we can apply
stoke's theorem to this circumstance so
stoke's theorem tells us that this is
going to be the same thing as
the surface integral over a piecewise
smooth surface bounded by this boundary
right over here and actually we'll pick
the simplest of all the of all of the
surfaces bounded by this i'll pick the
portion of the plane that is bounded by
c so s
is going to be the portion
portion
of the plane
of the plane y plus z is equal to 2
bounded
by
c so it's going to be the surface
integral over this we could have picked
any other surface too that's piecewise
smooth bounded by this but this is going
to be the easiest for us to work with we
have information on it it's a nice flat
it's at an incline but it's a nice flat
surface that we're going to be able to
operate on analytically and so we're
going to take the surface integral of
the curl
of our vector field dotted with and we
could say dot d s if we think of the
vector differential or we could say
dotted with the normal vector
dotted with the normal vector at any
point d s
times the little section of our surface
a little surface differential right over
there and we've talked already about
orientation so we want to make sure that
we get our orientation right we are
traversing it in this direction and if
we think about the little man analogy if
when he's walking in this direction if
he's walking with his head upwards then
the surface will be to his left and so
we want the normal vector that would
also go upward so the normal vector
would need to go the unit normal vector
would need to look something like that
the other analogy if you're twisting a
bottle cap like this then the bottle cap
will move in that direction in the
direction of this normal vector so we've
set it all up now all we have to do is
evaluate now we have to do is evaluate
this integral to evaluate it we have to
do a couple of things we want have to
come up with a parameterization for our
surface which shouldn't be too difficult
we've done it before when we evaluated
surface integrals and we also have to
calculate what the curl of f is going to
be and then we just need to evaluate the
double integral after all of that so
i'll do that in the next few videos